الى القدس حيث وصلت الى محيط مقر المكاتب
الحكوميه والكنيست الاسرائيلي في المدينه
مسيره تطالب الحكومه الاسرائيليه ومجلس
الحرب بالاسراع بابرام صفقه تبادل
والافراج عن الاسرى الاسرائيليين
المحتجزين في غزه المسيره التي ينظمها
مجموعه من الشبان من بلدات غلاف غزه كانت
قد انطلقت من ميدان الرهائن في تل ابيب
مطلع الاسبوع الجاري وت وقفت في الطريق
الى القدس في مدن وبلدات عده لحشد الدعم
لمطلب اعاده المحتجزين باي ثمن من المسيره
معنا مراسله الجزيره نجوان سمري والصوره
لديها من هناك
[تصفيق]
نجوان نعم بالفعل حسن هذه المسيره التي
انطلقت يوم الاحد الماضي من ما يعرف
بميدان الرهائن في تل ابيب باتجاه مدينه
القدس وصلت قبل قليل الى محيط المقار
الحكوميه في مدينه القدس حيث تقع الحكومه
الاسرائيليه والكنيست الاسرائيلي وبحسب ما
نراه في هذه المسيره التقديرات الاوليه
تشير الى عشرات الالاف وليس فقط الالاف من
المشاركين في هذه المسيره التي حشدت منذ
ان انطلقت من مدينه تلبيب وصولا الى مدينه
القدس اعداد كبيره جدا من المشاركون من
المشاركين عفوا كما تشاهدون يرفعون لافتات
بصور الاسرى الاسرائيليين المحتجزين في
غزه ويرددون هتافات تطالب بالعمل الفوري
من اجل الافراج عنهم جميعا الان الان هذه
هي الكلمه التي يرددونها بصوت عال طيله
الوقت الان الان نريدهم احياء ولا نريده
ولا نريد ان يعودوا الينا في توابيت هذا
هو الشعار الاول
لهذه المسيره ونحن لا نرى في الواقع نهايه
لهذه المسيره هذه المسيره بدات بتنظيم من
مجموعه قليله من حراك شبابي من احدى
مستوطنات غلاف غزه
وانطلقت ب ببضعه عشرات من تل ابيب واليوم
نرى هذا العدد الكبير للمشاركين الذين
يطالبون الحكومه ومجلس الحرب الاسرائيلي
بالعمل فورا من اجل الافراج عن كافه ال
اسرى المحتجزين من الاسرائيليين في قطاع
غزه هذا الحراك بالفعل اخذ بالتوسع نرى
حراك متصاعد يوما بعد يوم
قناه التلفزه الاسرائيليه
الث نشرت الليله
الماضيه عن معلومات تشير بان اسرائيل وضعت
في الايام الاخيره الماضيه مقترحا
جديدا قدمته للولايات المتحده
وبدورها قامت بتقديمه للوسيط القطري من
اجل مقترح جديد لتبادل الاسرى بين الجانب
الاسرائيلي وحركه حماس هذه القناه تتحدث
عن
مقترح يتضمن عده مراحل يبدا بانسحاب قوات
الاحتلال من داخل غزه تحديدا من المناطق
الماهوله وصولا الى البدء بمرحله تبادل
فئات معينه من الاسرى المحتجزين في غزه
مقابل الافراج عن اسرى فلسطينيين من سجون
الاحتلال ومقابل ايضا زياده ادخال
المعونات وال والمعدات الطبيه
الى داخل غزه وفي النهايه ينتقلون الى
المرحله الاخيره لانسحاب كامل لقوات
الاحتلال من داخل غزه ووقف شامل لاطلاق
النار لكن ذكرت ايضا القناه انه بحسب
المعلومات الاوليه فان حركه حماس تبدي
رفضها لهذا المقترح لانه لا يتضمن منذ
البدايه وقف شامل لاطلاق النار مع البدء
بعمليه التفاوض من اجل اتمام
هذه الصفقه من جهه اخرى هناك قلق متزايد
في اوساط عائلات الاسرى المحتجزين بعد عده
يعني اشارات او مؤشرات نشرتها وسائل اعلام
اسرائيليه بان الحكومه الاسرائيليه ومجلس
الحرب غير جدي بال المضي قدما من اجل
توقيع صفقه تبادل جديه وان هذا النشر
المتزايد عن خطوات تقوم بها الح الحكومه
الاسرائيليه ورئيس رئيس الحكومه بنيامين
نتنياهو هو فقط لامتصاص الغضب وتخفيف
الضغط الشعبي تحديدا في صفوف العائلات
والداعمين لهم كما تشاهدون هذا ما كانت قد
تحدثت عنه صحيفه هارس قبل ايام قليله بان
زياده النشر من قبل الجهات المسؤوله في
اسرائيل ومجلس الحرب بانهم يبذلون كل
الجهود من اجل الافراج عن الاسرى ال
المحتجزين في غزه ما هو الا فقط لتخفيف
الضغط وامتصاص غضب العائلات خاصه وان
نتنياهو يتحدث بخطاب متناقضين من جهه هو
يتحدث عن انه سيواصل هذه الحرب حتى تحقيق
اهدافها المعلنه بدايه او بداا بالقضاء
على حركه حماس وتقويه قدراتها العسكريه
والسلط ويه ولكن من جهه اخرى يقول بان
اسرائيل ستفعل كل شيء من اجل الافراج عنهم
وهناك تساؤل في اسرائيل اليوم اذا كان
نتنياهو يتحدث عن القضاء كليا على حركه
حماس ومن جهه اخرى يقول بانه يفعل كل شيء
اذا مع من سيتحدث مع من سيتفاوض ويشعرون
بانه غير صادق او على الاقل يشعرون بعدم
ثقه من جانبهم باتجاه هذ الحكومه باتجاه
مجلس الحرب يوم امس ايضا كان هناك حديث في
وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه متزايد عن
خلافات في داخل مجلس الحرب حول الاستمرار
في سير المعارك وفي
سير العمليات البريه في داخل غزه من ضمنها
ايضا قضيه الاسرى المحتجزين في غزه هناك
من يريد الانتقال الى المرحله الثالثه في
هذه الحرب الى مرحله العمليات المحدوده
وانسحاب القوات البريه الى محاور محدده
وفقا ايضا للمطلب الامريكي وايضا الضغط
باتجاه ابرام صفقه تبادل على راسهم الوزير
بيني جانس و ايزنكوت ايضا الذي يعتبر من
حزب بيني جانس في مقابل رئيس الحكومه
بنيامين نتانياهو والوزير وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي يوف جلنت الذان يعارضان ذلك
الى جانب رئيس هي اركان الجيش هفي حسن
شكرا لك نجوان سمري حدثتنا من
القدس